yeah and now it's four runs into rook c3  because otherwise uh white would be  winning  but there is rook c3 and after high five  no no there is luke stream checkmate  oh of course the g5 pawn is blocked so  here i have to drop back right  no maybe  here or after taking on g5 yeah or take  on g5 take and then i drop back yeah  yeah and now look at this  is a repetition because white cannot go  to g1 because that's a beauty  look at that mate  look at that checkmate wowzers  wow actually this very same motif  occurred in one of judit's games i  remember it because i entered it into  one of the courses that we are making  against loccie boy that was a beautiful  mate and that was actually after a queen  sack uh that was absolutely breathtaking  all right so um